I feel like the top rated show is pretty
safe you know we've been pretty safe so
far and you know for the most part with
top rated normally a bunch of users have
the most mostly correct opinion right
yeah so now we're going to judge if a
show deserves its popularity that's
right we're going to go to the
popularity list because there's a
difference between top rated and most
popular right yeah so this list is
compiled based on how many uh us of my
anime list have added these series onto
their favorite anime list not not based
off of like a star rating or anything
like that this is how many people
individual people have rated this show
as like I guess to them a 10 out of 10 I
just realized half of these shows are in
fortnite this this is probably where
epic games is getting their list from
they're just like all right what's the
next one we need add like literally half
of these are is is one punch man in
fortnite is it not I don't think it is
yet I'm surprised Titan we got my
Academia uh scroll down Sword Art Sword
Art Naruto is
there I don't think sure yet not yet de
Slayer yeah Tokyo Ghoul is number nine
Tokyo ghl Tokyo Ghoul is number nine all
right well let's go from number
one we we've already talked about this
so let's the most popular by 40,000 so
not not a lot but uh yeah death note and
Attack on Titan yeah which again I think
I I've always said this I think Death
Note is the perfect like first anime get
into anime and introduced I think Attack
on Titan also rightfully so I think
those two are the two shows that I would
be like you want to watch anime watch
these attack on is a perfect starter for
action oriented shows and Death Note is
the perfect non-action oriented show I
think you can look at you can see both
sides of what anime has to offer just
from these shows yeah the only problem I
have with recommending Attack on Titan
is the first anime is that no other
anime is like Attack on Titan so if
you're like dude can I get more of this
like no there is no more of this there's
nothing else like this I mean wouldn't
you say the same thing about death not
though Death Note kind of yeah but there
are Thrillers but not to the same
there's a lot of anime like death note
like not as but not as good as death
think about like f [__] like kaii or
like any mind game kind of show problem
but problem with shows like liar game or
kaiji is that like yeah all one outs is
that like it's it's not like appealing
visually as Death Note you know like
death note is a really pretty show it's
very yeah a lot of cool Rel yeah code
gas again you know I I've seen some
people complaining about their [__]
triangular face chin I'm actually
shocked that codos isn't higher I I
thought in my head that it was like top
five in popularity okay is there
anything that sticks out here that
doesn't deserve to be in the yeah five
five and six five and six five and six
but like it's hard to it's hard to
explain to an anime fan who who gets
into anime in the past 5 years just how
much of a choke hold sword do online has
at at Peak when sword do online came out
it was like the only show oh yeah it was
the only thing anyone [__] spoke
about and it dominated online culture
because there just wasn't as much anime
out there's no shows about the real BS
The Gamers out there I think people hey
man don't discredit my boy do hack like
that right
they the [__] out did it
first if I wanted to watch a camping
anime I'd watch your Camp okay cuz
that's what do hack was it was a it's
not a gamer anime is a camp it wasn't
for the male fantasy Joey and sort
online is for the male fantasy you want
to log
into you want to be the god gamer it's
sort out online this show was so [__]
popular not so much now thank God but it
was in it was ridiculous how popular
this show I got to ask it would be in
fortnite if it came out today Joe Joe I
I got to ask Joe all right personal
question yeah did you watched sword Us
online before it got popular yeah and
you had formed your opinion about it
yeah as yeah yeah not based not based on
any it's okay it's okay to say you
didn't like it no no no no I I I I
remember dude this is this
is no this is a really well-known meme
in my community that when I was writing
anime reviews on my website before I
even started making videos I gave the
first season of sort out online a nine
out of 10 did you actually yeah it's
it's a and and this is a and this is a
something that I have owned up to many
many times right it wasn't until oh my
God the biggest plot TST yeah it wasn't
until the second season came out right
Al online or I guess the second half of
the first season came out that I started
to see issues and then it made me
rewatch from the beginning to be like
was I just being swallowed up by the
hype of the show and then I started to
pinpoint all the problems and I'm like
ah I think I was just blinded by the
hype of this show I've never seen a show
fumble season 2 so much oh my God yeah
alame was the biggest fumble and it
fumbled so hard that it made me question
if actual like the first half of I
distinctly remember watching s online
season one and I thought holy [__] it's
a show for me it's a show that gets me
and my my in my like innate desires okay
I will give sort online credit in saying
that I think the first two episodes are
sold
online season one was good no legit I
think the first two episodes of Saw on
line I think had a lot of potential to
go in a direction that would have been a
lot more interesting I [__] Lov
season one I I had a great time with it
uh I I still think go go but yeah season
2 was such [__] dog [__] yeah season
so yeah I don't know why
everyone everyone liked Sword Art Online
until they didn't and I just you have a
moment I checked out when just when they
started making a family I was like what
the [__] is this what the [__] is this I
checked out was then yui that [__]
small girl that was the point where I
was like you've gone in the wrong
direction I was like if I okay if I'm
playing this game if I'm in this game
I'm selling that thing for XP or or I'm
finding a way to make use of this kid
I'm not [__] raising it what the [__]
yeah that was the moment where like all
logic was thrown out the window and it
just took the story in a direction like
cuz the concept of sort out on line
could have gone in like a really dark
and brooding Direction where it like you
could actually feel the stakes of like
these characters that were put in place
right but it took itself in a direction
where it didn't really highlight that
like Doom and Gloom that the world was
built around and instead focused on like
so how the [__] can I RIS up ASA like
like no one gives a [__] like you
completely forgot about the whole point
of the story that you placed your
characters in and put in some [__]
romance story behind it and it just
ruined everything by CU he he wrote
asa's very boring generally and then
gave up on ASA and was like let's just
introduce new girls [__] it all right
yeah I mean I think it's it's
interesting right because I look back to
sort outline season one and I generally
think that there were some really cool
ideas in season one I think we I think
we I think a lot of we again first
couple of episodes introduced so many
cool ideas that could have been used in
so many interesting ways in the story
and then Kahari was just like yeah but I
really want ARs and C to [__] like
that's all he cared about well I I think
and that's what all the viewers cared
about apparently yeah I mean boss
battles in Sword outs online it's still
[__] hype of yes it's [__] power
fantasy but I remember seeing Kyo get
the [__] second swort out didn't
really think too much about how fair
this was as a game mechanic that the one
person also how much it didn't make
sense yeah yeah I I at the point if it
was a real game it' be [__] stupid be
like what a [__] dumb mechanic yeah
exactly well that guy gets two swords
because he has quick reaction times [__]
that guy what the [__] yeah that just
makes Faker even more [__] op what
the [__] man yeah but that's the thing
right is that like like you know and
when I initially went back to rewatch it
and I started to like actually dissect
the show for what it was and I realized
this could have gone in a direction that
I would have really thoroughly enjoyed
and you know subsequent shows after sord
online came out actually did go in
directions that were interesting and
actually utilize the story in the way
that it was intended to be like Log
Horizon for example where as s online I
feel the biggest sin that s online aded
was that it just fumbled a really
interesting idea I I think I think Log
Horizon fumbled it too you think I feel
like it just couldn't figure out what it
wanted to do I think it was in a better
trajectory than it was though I I did
Peak blog Horizon I enjoyed more than
than Peak sort out online for me I felt
like Lon also kind of was
like what do I want this to be now I
don't know but sort out online yeah it
was insane when it came out and I'm not
surprised that it's number five however
I mean it's such an easy show to
recommend going to defend alisation
though I'm still going to
defend I think the longer time passes
the more we'll see sort of online slowly
drop down because you know people aren't
really I don't think as many people are
watching it anymore no no there's people
like me is a guy trash people watch and
I feel like it's going to become an old
internet meme in like 20 years like oh
SW online is so bad